quand on achète du sirop d'érable à
l'épicerie on a le choix entre quatre
couleurs de sirop mais en fait c'est un
peu réducteur c'est comme si on limitait
nos choix de 20 selon les couleurs blanc
rouge ou rosé pourtant le sirop d'érable
c'est un liquide très complexe qui
comporte des centaines de nuances de
goût des acériculteurs des scientifiques
et des cuisiniers valorise d'ailleurs
ces nuances là malgré certains obstacles
[Musique]
c'est la fin du printemps la cèze de
l'érable à sucre ne coule plus les
tubulures sont vides
on pourrait croire que la saison du
sirop d'érable tire à sa fin
mais pour la division inspection du
centre acer spécialisé en acériculture
elle n'en est qu'à ses débuts il ya une
quinzaine d' équipes des classificateurs
de qualité qui sont actives sur le
territoire
chaque équipe comprend souvent trois
personnes donc le classificateur lui
même le vérificateur de qualité qui est
la personne qui goûte le produit est
apprécié à deux autres personnes qui
l'assistent ce sont les auxiliaires
qu'on appelle la classification est
vraiment du début mars à la fin
septembre
donc nos stocks et des régions qui
commence à faire du sirop où commence la
classification suis quand l'iss est en
train de faire du sirop mais ceux-ci
reconstruite dans l'ouest c'est pas mal
terminée mais nous on est à la
classification
c'est pour tout le travail il sait
continue de mois en mois tous les bars y
de la production québécoise sont goûtés
et classés soit près de 350000 barry
chaque année à raison de 250
échantillons par jour par gunter
et
les vérificateurs passe les sirops à
transmission de lumière on va retrouver
du douar et on peut retrouver du en bray
on va avoir le foncé et on va voir le
très foncé selon ses caractéristiques le
sirop sera destiné soit au marché de la
transformation ou des épiceries où il
sera vendu selon sa couleur
mais certains ont décidé d'aller au-delà
des 4 catégories depuis plus de 20 ans
line girard est acéricultrices à
l'érablière casey al en estrie elle
goûte son sirop chaque jour de
production chez nous le goût qu'on
arrive à développer
c'est un peu vannes et c'est très
agréable
ces noisettes et caramel ce sur caramel
brûlé un petit peu vers la fin de la
saison mais c'est à peu près les savoir
qu'on est capable de sortir on est
capables d'aller dans plein de choses au
niveau de l'erreur
[Musique]
chef renommé helena loureiro sublime le
sirop d'érable comme elle le faisait
traditionnellement avec le mille
moi personnellement je travaille les
quatre couleurs 2d l'érable pour
différentes 13,7 conjugue août les
sirops pur c'est vraiment cette goutte
l'érable que je sens vraiment dame à
gauche ici c'est là que ça explose
toutes les saveurs et tout les goûts le
sirop contient plus clair il ya plus de
gagner
elle vient plus doré c'est plus
caramélisées plus de goût du caramel et
tout ça convié vers le fond c c'est
vraiment chocolat concentrent dans le
sirop foncé s'agit pour aller mais
pétoncles avec le beurre d'érable et je
l' ai fini avec le sirop font aussi ça
va chercher en goût chocolat thé vert
les pétoncles et le foie gras
ça fait une complicité dans mon assiette
vous avez des bétons qu'au québec vous
avez les pommes au québec et vous avez
le sirop d'érable
alors c'est vraiment très typique
événements elle pense que les goûts du
sirop d'érable pourrait être valorisé
comme le sont ceux du miel ou de l'huile
d'olive
[Musique]
les scientifiques du centre acer et du
ministère de l'agriculture et
agroalimentaire canada sont du même avis
ensemble ils ont créé un outil pour
identifier les nuances de goût du sirop
d'érable
on a travaillé à développer une roue des
flaveurs de l'érable une rue des fleurs
de l'érable s'est un peu vocabulaire
scientifique qu'on a développé un peu
comme pour les vins finalement donc on
l'a développée spécifiquement pour le
sirop d'érable pour pouvoir se parler
la roue compte une centaine de flaveurs
différentes
regroupés en treize familles comme celle
du florales des confiseries ou du
végétal le boisé fait partie du groupe
végétale par exemple on peut aussi
retrouver la famille fruité qui nous
fait penser par exemple à distribuer
comme le citron l'orangé
on retrouve parfois des épices ou si on
retrouve aussi les empyreumatiques et
les confiseries qui sont des notes de
sucre et des notes de de cuisson de
différentes intensités
c'est surprenant de voir à quel point on
peut retrouver différentes choses en
sirop d'érable en termes de saveur c'est
certain que il ya des attributs qu'on
retrouve plus souvent d'autres certains
sirops gouttes la guimauve
le café le beurre la cannelle ou encore
le clou de girofle
une quinzaine de goûteurs ont été
spécialement formés au québec pour
caractériser les flaveurs du sirop
d'érable
ils ont devant eux des échantillons qui
sont disposés dans des pots en brie pour
cacher la couleur pour ne pas être
influencé par la couleur du produit et
en silence calmement ils vont déguster
le produit et tenter de réfléchir et
pour lui attribuer une note selon le
vocabulaire de la roue la première étape
de la dégustation consiste à sentir le
sirop le humer avant même d'y goûter
parce que la flaveur se définit par
l'ensemble des sensations perçues par
l'infection
les papilles gustatives et les
récepteurs tactile en bouche après
suivant le goûter qui vont le faire
circuler dans leur bouche c'est le qu'on
parle des tapis augusta si la mémoire
sensorielle
les sens ont fait appel à tous leurs
sens
c'est pour ça que le travail devient
assez fusée parce que de goûter de
goûter de cracher louer leurs meilleurs
amis
[Musique]
contrairement au vin la science du sirop
d'érable est encore jeune on ne sait pas
si le terroir a une influence sur le
goût par exemple on s'est mis à étudier
son appartement au centre acer depuis
plusieurs années pour essayer de
décortiquer qu'est ce que contient un
sirop d'érable et quels sont les
molécules qui viennent influencer le
goût de ceux ci roland sur le terrain
les acériculteurs ont constaté
l'influencent de plusieurs facteurs sur
le goût du sirop comme le type d'arbres
y aller rabaste mais yossi l'érable
rouge qu'on entend ce qui amène des
goûts différents une de l'eau
la serv évolué tout au long de la
production
c'est ce qui explique souvent vaut faire
un sirop plus denrées en début de saison
qui va devenir ambrée et vers la fin de
la saison va devenir foncé au début de
la saison l'eau d'érable contient un
sucre appelé saccharose
quand on nous la couleur du sirop et
pâle avec l'avancée du temps des sucres
des bactéries et des micro-organismes
s'accumulent dans les tubulures il
transforme alors le saccharose en deux
autres sucres le glucose et le fructose
lors de la cuisson
ces deux sucres s'active et donnent à
leur sirop plus foncée c'est la raison
pour laquelle la couleur du sirop
changent au fil de la saison
on peut peser jusqu'à will sirop
d'érable sagot les rames pis c'est tout
non il ya plein de subtilités puis on en
est responsable de ces subtilités l'eau
en effet l'étape qui a le plus
d'influencé sur le goût se retrouve dans
les mains des artisans acériculteurs
aussi appelé les sucriers
il joue sur la température et le temps
de cuisson plus longue et la cuisson
plus le sirop sera foncé au lieu de dire
quand on fait jeu sans produire ont
épuisé
quand on a fait faire des années cette
étape aura tard l'un d'eux on s'est dit
on va jusqu'à huit pieds pour développer
le maximum de sa vente possible
toutes les saveurs du sirop d'érable
vont se développer à cet endroit l'eau à
sève de l'arbre contient environ 2 % de
sucre pour obtenir du ciron l'eau
d'érable doit bouillir à 100 4 degrés
celsius pour atteindre le chiffre clef
de 66 brics autrement dit 66 % de sucre
c'est le point d'équilibré sous la barre
de 66 brics le sirop ne se conserve pas
avec une cuisson plus élevé il se
cristallise et se transforme en tir ou
en beurre d'érable technos qu'on a
commencé à faire c'est qu'on le fait
cuire un petit peu plus pour ensuite le
réduire le ramener à 66 et ça permet
d'aller chercher des saveurs qui sont de
plus en plus et ram avec un peu autre
chose parce que le sirop d'érable ça
goûte peu juste le sirop d'érable
les consommateurs sont curieux de ces
nuances alors chez kaze al on valorise
les flaveurs en produits dérivés de
l'érable et on vend détail autant que
possible mais contrairement au miel ou
au vin le marché du sirop d'érable est
conçu pour uniformiser son goût tous les
sirops de la province sont mélangés par
couleur c'est décevant finalement de
travailler fin parce qu'il ya plusieurs
entreprises qui font comme nous de
travailler fort pour essayer de
développer des saveurs et qu'au final
dans bien des cols et sirops sont tout
mélanger il ya des transformateurs qui
se questionnent ils font comme nous
parce que finalement l'industrie est pas
si vieille que ça fait cinquante
soixante ans compte on fait vraiment la
production l'eau à grande échelle sirop
d'érable des acériculteurs sont prêts
les consommateurs sont intéressés et les
scientifiques ont déjà créé la roue des
flaveurs mais la grande distribution
n'est pas encore au rendez vous
l'industrie agroalimentaire à plusieurs
fonctions entre autres le consommateur
qui sera un 18 cas ils l'achètent tel
produit il veut toujours retrouver la
même constance dans produits donc les
grands transformateurs aigrement tant
qu'aliment ces marchés le veulent avoir
un produit standardisé avec l'état
actuel des connaissances il est
difficile de reproduire à l'exactitude
ce délicieux goût de vanille noisette
obtenu après la cuisson dans matin
d'avril
d'autant plus que le goût peut varier au
cours d'une même journée souvent déjà
vont éviter de mettre en marché un
produit qui est trop unique parce que si
on habitue un consommateur quelque chose
qu'on pourra jamais reproduire
mais nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est
d'aller encore plus loin de dire qu'un
sirop et il paye denrées mais il peut
goûter boisé il peut goûter la vanille
puis faire la même chose pour chacune
des catégories
depuis peut-être même de laisser de côté
les couleurs mais bien de parler de
leurs savants on aimerait bien un jour
voir des pastilles sur le sirop d'érable
un peu comme on voit sur les vins à la
saq
donc on aimerait bien avoir des
pastilles qui aiderait le consommateur à
s'orienter un peu plus au niveau du goût
parce qu'il est intéressé et ils le
demandent les sirops d'érable du québec
qui a connu partout à travers du monde
alors je pense que c'est une richesse
naturelle parce que c'est unique c'est
un succès unique
on développe vraiment tout ça tout si
goûteux che savard l'axé sert j'ai
trouvé magnifique qui sait dans quelques
années nos cuisines regorgeront
peut-être d'autant de sirop d'érable
différent que de vin de miel ou d'huile
d'olive
que